hey 42 here years ago famed country
singer songwriter a Nobel Prize winner
Bob Dylan gave an unsettling interview
on 60 minutes when asked why he was
continuing to go out and perform after a
five decade long career
Dylan said that he had made a deal with
something a long time ago and he was
simply holding up his end of the bargain
when the interviewer asked him what he
had made a bargain for Dylan said it was
to get where he is now his fame success
accolades an enormous musical talent
naturally the interviewer wanted to know
who or what Dylan had made a bargain
with but the answer was not what he
expected Dylan said he had made a
bargain with the chief of this world
this earth and the world we cannot see
this isn't the first time Dylan has made
such a revelation
back in 2008 he commented that he had
traveled to the crossroads and made a
deal of something and when he came back
he was the man he is today
this might seem strange but in the music
industry especially the blues there are
countless legends of figures going to
the crossroads and making a deal with a
very specific entity and then they
return with incredible music prowess
such as legendary blues musicians Robert
and Tommy Johnson and what's interesting
is that in Martin Scorsese's documentary
nodirectionhome which traces the life of
Dylan a childhood friend makes an
intriguing comment stating that Dylan
used to play at parties and he was okay
just average but after returning from a
few months in New York
Dylan was performing feats of musical
skill his friends couldn't believe and
another friend even referred to him as a
shape changer or a man possessed and so
the ordinary Robert Zimmerman and
Dylan's real name
had begun his journey towards becoming
the legendary Bob Dylan but who was this
chief of the earth and the world we
cannot see the strange entity that Dylan
had struck a deal with
it would be natural to assume that Dylan
was referring to God right well the New
Testament poses another idea that it is
the devil not God who is the Prince of
this world throughout history there have
been various myths legends or even
first-hand admissions of men making
deals with the devil so let's explore
some ostensibly true stories of men who
apparently signed a contract in blood to
make a deal with the devil some of these
stories so unsettling they may play on
your mind
but first what saw he was the devil
anyway the devil or Satan Lucifer
Beelzebub and mephistopheles appears
across multiple religions and cultures
around the world in fact he's so common
that some might consider him or the idea
of him to be an innate quality of human
beings and he always has one thing in
common he is the personification of evil
an extremely hostile and destructive
force whose chief weapons are deception
and temptation perhaps the best concept
of the devil is in John Milton's poem
Paradise Lost where the devil is two
fallen angel Lucifer whose great pride
leads him to rebel against God he is
portrayed as a charismatic passionate
but deeply flawed entity who is
incapable of doing good or even seeing
how his schemes will harm himself at one
point he quite literally states he is
going to make a heaven out of hell as a
man of science I'm skeptical of any
fallen angel at Mawson to a pitchfork
wielding goat so I consider the devil to
be more of a meta physical manifestation
of humanity's vices a reminder that our
selfish inclinations might lead us
astray and lead us to self ruin but
regardless of what you believe there are
some legends of folk who made a deal
with the devil that stand well apart
from the rest not just because they
involve notable figures from history but
because of the bizarre unsettling and
disturbing consequences that followed
the first and perhaps the most famous
legend of a man making a deal
devil is Faust a story that has been
told time and time again by writers such
as to again give wild man Marlow and
most famously Goethe Faust began as a
morality tale warning against the costs
of worldly ambition goethe's faust
tells the story of a man who in his
search for ultimate knowledge falls into
suicidal despair at his failed efforts
and makes a deal with the devil who
appears before him offering a helping
hand but what if I told you this story
was actually based on a real man a man
who seemed every bit is touched by the
hand of evil as his fictitious
counterpart German doctor Johann Georg
Faust was a notable but incredibly
mysterious figure in the 15th and early
16th centuries for around 30 years he
appeared all over Europe performing
magic tricks offering horoscopes and was
often accused of fraud and regularly
claimed to be a physician doctor of
philosophy Alchemist and an astrologer
all sources indicate that he was a
widely traveled and widely known man and
all these sources testify to his
incredibly evil nature in fact his
reputation at the time was steeped in
the supernatural
he claimed he could repeat and exceed
all of the miracles of Christ and he was
reported to travel with a doc and a
horse with the dog's shape-shifting into
a servant at will he even had dozens of
grimoires magical texts attributed to
him it was thought that he was in league
with the devil and had made some kind of
deal with him so much so that he was
officially denounced by the church
whilst most scholars of his time scoffed
at his magical abilities he was taken
very seriously by notable figures such
as Martin Luther continually accused of
fraud and other things like sodomy Faust
was eventually banned from cities or
denied entry one
he was recognized but it wasn't until
his death that things turned to truly
strange killed in a chemical explosion
fast body was discovered to be heavily
mutated so much so that perhaps he had
been mutated prior to the explosion many
assumed this was at all that Lucifer's
evil hadn't acted on Faust to contort
his body into a maligned mess and more
strangely despite the fact fast body was
laid on its back it was continually
found to have turned over and over and
over again to face the very bowels of
the earth no matter how many times
someone righted it that is a story of
Faust from history or rather the man
known as Faust according to historians
Faust was his assumed name however the
true identity of this man and whatever
deal he made with the devil may never
truly be known
the second legend is that of Bernard
Fokker the fastest sailor of his age in
the 17th century the Dutch Empire
touched every corner of the known world
with colonies on most continents the
Dutch Empire wielded enormous power and
wealth driven largely by its control of
extremely valuable spices
one such colony in Jakarta Indonesia had
spices that were desired all around the
world the problem was the journey from
the Netherlands to Indonesia took at
best a whole year making the trade of
valuable spices extraordinarily lengthy
and vulnerable to piracy sinking disease
and much more yet despite this
incredible distance and the perils
involved one captain Bernard Fokker was
consistently completing the journey in
his little as free most how was this
possible
there was no Suez Canal to travel
through this meant Fokker would have had
to be in sailing around Europe Africa
and southern Asia to get there that is
no small journey even for modern boats
but in the 17th century this was
impossible two hundred years later this
journey still took T Clippers the
fastest ships on the seas for months
perhaps even more unbelievable is that
the ship's letters verify the journey
time as correct unless the letters were
faked Fokker was actually sailing this
extraordinary journey and as little as
three months but fake documents wouldn't
explain third party accounts that
support [ __ ] movements and time scales
stories of the times hold the fuck-ass
strange and menacing character it was
said that all who served on to the
captor were controlled by an iron fist
and were punished to such diabolical
extremes that [ __ ] made their lives a
living hell of endless misery but there
was another rumor that was whispered
around [ __ ]
one that explained his unnatural speed
he had sold his soul to the devil in
order to be the fastest sailor who ever
lived the devil had agreed and made
supernatural modifications to [ __ ] his
ship allowing it to reach speeds that
were impossible for any contemporary
vessel and so [ __ ] became just what he
bargained for the fastest and most
famous sailor of his age but that is not
where his story ends
because legend has it after [ __ ] had
enjoyed the fruits of his deal the devil
had come back to claim his Jew he
sentenced [ __ ] and his ship to sail
the oceans for all eternity as captain
of none other than the legendary go ship
the Flying Dutchman doomed to never find
port again and since its sighting near
the Cape of Good Hope in 1709 the Flying
Dutchman has haunted sailors as a
terrible specter and a reminder of the
true cost of doing business with the
devil eternal damnation now to return to
the theme we touched on at the start of
the video the likes of Bob Dylan and
Robert Johnson aren't the only musicians
who have supposedly made a deal with the
devil
there are countless stories of hopeful
musicians wandering out to the
crossroads and coming back with a
complete almost supernatural mastery of
their instruments but amongst all these
stories there is one figure from history
that stands head and shoulders above the
rest
niccolò paganini in perhaps the most
satanic story of the lot it is said that
his relationship with the devil began
before he was even born it was rumoured
that pregnant with her son Paganini's
mother sought to commune with the devil
in order to assure that her son would
become a great virtuoso and whatever
deal she made certainly paid off but not
without it costs by age 13 Paganini
skills with the violin were progressing
it's such a rate that his master
declared there was nothing more he could
teach him he was a natural child prodigy
and what came to others only through
decades of effort came to him with
almost supernatural ease by age 15 he
was already performing solo tours
astonishing his audience with his skill
and confidence but this is where
Paganini's problems began although
enormous Lee gifted with a rare and
valuable skill Paganini fell into a
breakdown and swiftly turned to alcohol
to ease his torment this may have been
one of the reasons why despite being a
young man enduring enormous Fame and
success Paganini was rapidly seduced by
gambling womanizing and even more
alcoholism and now someone settling
rumors about Paganini began to emerge
with one popular story saying that
Paganini had murdered a woman he'd
seduced used her intestines as violin
strings and imprisoned her soul within
his instrument forever but whilst
outlandish many of these rumors had
roots within the bizarre and unusual
character of Paganini himself firstly
his skill was on power
he could play at a rate of 12 notes per
second and he performed and popularized
complex techniques almost effortlessly
on none other than the violin which was
known to many as the devil's instrument
but perhaps most striking and most
satanic was his appearance he was said
to have enormous ly long fingers with
lengthy immaculate snails his skin was
ghostly pale and he had hollow sunken
cheeks thin lips and his tall thin body
was always dressed in black this may be
why too many people he was thought to be
the devil himself it was reported by
some audience members that a terrible
bolt of lightning struck during one of
his performances writers Paganini bowed
and what audience member claimed to have
saw some kind of supernatural being
helping Paganini as he performed
eventually after age and disease ravaged
his body and he had long retired from
performing Paganini died of larynx
cancer with one of his final actions
being to turn away the priests who
offered him his last rites a decision
taken by many to indicate his satanic
connection his body was soon after
refused by the church but after years of
being transported around he was finally
forgiven by Pope Gregory and buried in
Parma northern Italy lastly there is one
final man said to have made a deal with
the devil and in fact he is a man who
supposedly tried to best the devil at
his own game after all as the saying
goes it's no sin to cheat the devil
Jonathan Moulton was a legendary civil
war hero who came into enormous wealth
in later life whilst he may have been a
fantastic soldier I'm respected for his
feats in battle he was simultaneously
despised by the poor Puritan population
of his local town the reason he
frequently flaunted his enormous wealth
in front of them with little regard for
how much it was rubbed in their faces in
fact he had risen to wealth so quickly
it was widely believed there was some
supernatural Humbert
this was why when his house suddenly
burned down for no obvious reason many
suspected that Malta had brought about
some kind of unholy retribution upon
himself molten took further actions that
damaged the public's view of him when
his wife suddenly died he waited no time
in marrying her much younger attractive
friends and then flaunting her around
town it was even whispered in the
community that the spirit of his
deceased wife would haunt his new wife's
marital bed seeking to reclaim the ring
that had been stolen from her but the
story of how Moulton suddenly came to be
opulent in the first place is the most
disturbing of all offering his soul in
return for riches molten made a pact
with the devil and in return the devil
would fill two of his boots which were
hanging over his fireplace to the brim
with gold each day the devil accepted
the arrangement and soon molten was a
fabulously rich man but boot full of
gold soon became insufficient for him
and driven mad by his greed he ordered
that larger and larger boots be made and
hung over his fireplace so that each day
the devil would give him more gold than
he had previously seeing that their
arrangement hadn't changed the devil
continued filling Waltons boots to the
brim as promised but it was here that
Moulton decided to trick the devil
coming up with the idea that if he cut
the bottom off the boots the coins would
pour out onto the floor and try as he
might the devil could never fill them
being left to poor and poor and
unsurprisingly the devil didn't take
this deceit very well discovering
Moulton's trick and finding the coins
spilling out over the floor the devil
was filled with incandescent
age and legend has it burnt Moulton's
house to the ground he and his family
barely escaped alive but that's not
where our story ends
years later when molten died at the age
of 61 his body vanished from his coffin
it seemed that the devil hadn't
forgotten what happened and had dragged
molten body and all straight down to
hell and it said that all I was left in
the coffin was a small pot of gold
bearing a demonic insignia whatever
actually happened to Moulton we may
never know now you might want to
consider what you would sell your soul
for and would it be worth it because as
the Gospel of Matthew says what good
will it be for a man if he gains the
whole world yet forfeits his soul thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
then please consider supporting me on
patreon it really helps me to continue
to make these videos the links in the
description also you can get your hands
on a first edition signed copy of my
book stick a flag in it a thousand years
of bizarre history from Britain and
Beyond by going to unbound publishing
and ordering yours today
links in the description thank you